denis podalydès bonjour bonjour merci
nous accorder un peu de votre précieux
temps nous sommes là à la comédie
française
car vous êtes en pleine répétition à ce
qu'on m'a dit d'une pièce qui s'appelle
lucrèce borgia de victor hugo
écrite en 1832 32 ha oui je crois
32-33 jeu cissé 32 f enfin bref voilà
qui a été comme on dit a joué par
antoine vitez en 1985 elle a été montée
par antoine vitez
oui c'est ça à peu près et puis c'est
quoi exactement car oui ça n'est pas une
année prennent un des acteurs de la
distribution qui était dans cette mise
en scène à qui revient la vie et dans la
troupe tout simplement oui alors il a
changé de rôle ah bah oui parce que la
burqa parce que
j'ai pas y'a presque pas 30 ans quand
même des mois si non 85 et 30 ça fait 30
ans voilà comment ça veut dire être
autant on avait 18 ans monsieur meuble
comme of bon peu importe peu importe
et donc voilà nous on est on est ravi
d'avoir à faire à vous parce que vous
êtes un déjà vous êtes né à versailles
ainsi que j'ai vu près il y avait vécu à
jusqu'à 26 ans quand même jusqu'à l'âge
de 26 ans en janvier ou à l'école j'ai
été l'école maternelle du pâtre lebrun à
l'école marcel lafitte ans puis au
collège pierre de nolhac d'accord et
puis au lycée hoche suis au lycée
labruyère où j'ai fait une hypokhâgne au
lycée la bruyère est d'accord et après
je suis parti à paris mais j'ai continué
habiter à versailles pendant que je
poursuivrai mes études au lycée henri iv
et puis ensuite au conservatoire
national
j'étais encore domiciliés à versailles
aux quais et vous avez commencé à
prendre des cours de théâtre à quel
moment
alors j'ai toujours fait du théâtre à
l'école de williams à terme quasiment la
maternelle
et puis dans quand je suis arrivé en
seconde au lycée hoche j'ai rencontré
colette au monde qui a été un personnage
essentiel pour moi c'est qui colette
hautmont j'avoue ne pas cadrer c'est une
comédienne metteur en scène que qui est
disparu il ya deux ans et qui animait un
atelier qu'elle faisait dans les
différents lycées de versailles et de
des yvelines même après c'est
aujourd'hui et est là c'était les
marcels tassencourt qui était la
directrice y avait eu linux ce concours
interscolaire qui réunissait des troupes
d'élèves de toute la région et qui
pendant quinze jours au théâtre
montansier donner des spectacles
d'accord que vous répétiez alors au
lycée qu'on respecte et au lycée pendant
l'année et quand j'ai découvert ça je
plongeais
dans ce bain la has et muriel mayette a
fait partie de ce coût augmente à scaer
les serrures nuss dont une est devenu
célèbre par plus belle la vie
quantité d'autres acteurs se sont ils
avaient lieu tous les ans et je me suis
bien à paris et ça se passait dans un
vrai théâtre avec de vrais lumière
devrait publier confessionnelles moi
j'ai fait mes premiers spectacles en
tant qu acteur metteur en scène est
aussi écrivain là avec une frise un oui
j'écris j'écris des pièces
l'atelier de l'hexagone et cycles
d'accord qui s'appelait la lune sur un
fils je me rappelle qui avait obtenu le
prix
j'ai connu tous les bonheurs du théâtre
ça c'est sûr une quinzaine de jours avec
des répétitions extrêmement active très
très très poussées donc s'affirmer
contre seulement way votre goût et votre
détermination
oui à être acteur et m messieurs à ce
moment là je ne dissocie pas du tout la
vie scolaire
le théâtre de la vie scolaire puisque
c'était dans le cadre de l'école que se
passait ce concours interscolaire et
donc je ne
mon but était d'être professeur de faire
du théâtre avec mes élèves aiment bien
quand je serais devenu l'idée pratique
c'était ça dans le fantasme
je voulais devenir la plus grande
vedette du monde
ouais mais ça c'était je savais très
mais c'était clairement un fantasme et
que dans le domaine pratique bien je
m'orientais vert et c'est le concordat
scolaire qui m'as tu m'as donné qu'il
m'a apporté comme ça le premier
sentiment du succès le sentiment du trac
le sentiment du travail du répertoire de
des rôles et lucrèce borgia dites moi
pourquoi ce choix de vous allez donc
être le metteur en scène vous avez
choisi cette pièce j'ai pas choisi en
fait pas plus réel mayenne qui m'a
demandé à demander de mettre la pièce
m'a demandé si j'étais d'accord pour lé
j'imagine on vous oblige pas et pourquoi
ce choix de guillaume gallienne on
lucrèce borgia ça oui ça en fait je là
c'est vous qui avez choisi
ah ça c'est moi qui choisis oui je sais
les acteurs j'ai choisi les parce que en
relisant la pièce je m'intéressais à ce
qu'elle a
non parce qu'elle peut avoir de réaliste
ce qu'elle peut avoir d'un drame qui
pourrait la part en terre d'autres haram
du 19e siècle ou à des pièces plus
anciennes des pièces plus réaliste
historique de shakespeare par exemple
mais ce qu'elle contient deux d'onirique
de noir de cauchemardesque légendaire un
idéal et pour le passage de lucrèce
borgia qui est un monstre à l'intérieur
de quel arsenal une âme maternelle c'est
un océan de noirceur dans laquelle une
goutte de lait maternel donne suffit à
teinter tout leur est dû et donc je
n'arrivais pas à me satisfaire
je voyais beaucoup il ya plein d'actrice
dans la maison qu'il aurait joué
magnifiquement mais j'ai voulu chercher
une apparence dans laquelle était
enfermé quelque chose
voilà est l'invitée d'un guillaume
gallienne oui et alors rassemblé n'y a
pas du tout fait son film c'est ce que
j'allais vous demandez et le spectacle
vous l'aviez vu le spectacle bigard ce
matin je l'avais vu et ce qui m'avait
frappé c'était l'entrée en scène une
entrée japonisante de guillaume et
quelques attitudes féminines quelques
attitudes et d'autres parmi d'autres qui
vous ont frappé plus les certaine
attitude n'est que ça fait même pas un
ton devoir c'était même pas c'était une
cheminée était beaucoup plus
fantomatique d'accord et quant aux coûts
plus stylisé donc c'est pas du tout le
personnage figé dans son film d'accord
et sage ça m'a fait rêver et apparaît
aussi une fascination pour l'acteur tout
à fait imprévisible que guillaume
peu de même que j'avais monté fantasio
avec cécile brune dans le rôle masculin
de fantasio non pas parce que je voulais
une femme pour jouer un homme mais
soudain j'avais eu le désir profond de
vouloir cécile brune dans ce rôle là
lorsque au théâtre je m'autorise toutes
les conventions y compris et peut-être
la plus que la petite une très ancienne
confiance maison et donc en pensant à
lucrèce à partir du moment où l'image de
guillaume a s'est imposée presque comme
fantôme
ce n'était pas un choix tout très
rationnel c'est un choix que j'ai
ensuite combattu et mais qui revenait
toujours parmi d'autres choix et
jusqu'au moment où je me suis dit mais
non on va travailler ensemble à créer
cette chimère ce personnage mystérieux
monstrueux qu'est lucrèce borgia lui
donner une humanité justement vont
parler de mouvement de certaines
attitudes bien précises qui vous ont
fasciné chez lui pendant son spectacle
et quand vous parlais justement dans à
la peur matamore de cette fascination
pour les mouvements des toreros le geste
du poignet des choses extrêmement
précise et etc
je me demandais si votre de votre
travail de metteur en scène vous étiez
attachés comme ça à faire reproduire par
les acteurs des les mouvements enfin est
ce que pour vous c'est joli geste tout à
fait attiré par faith je dire la souris
bien mais par une stylisation qui ré
parfois jusqu'à la chorégraphie jouer
voilà à dire mais là ça ne se décrète
pas mais ce ne sont pas des danseurs
maintenant ce sont des gars qu'on doit
toujours composer avec d'abord la
liberté d'un acteur la situation
dramatique le caractère qu'il joue si
fait que c'est pas ce ne sont pas comme
on comme un des danseurs il sait pas où
il ya parfois quand vous
un ballet il ya du talent de fond
abstraite là c'est pas du tout le cas
donc c'est une visée
c'est pas une donnée de base et en plus
c'est quelque chose qu'on construit peu
à peu mais là est de fait dans lucrèce
borgia j'essaie de pousser plus loin
ce désir ce désir de la forme ce goût de
la forme est ce ce goût du geste ont
dessiné une grande précision j'imagine
dans une oui il faut une très grande
précision mais pas simplement même la
précision du geste fou une précision du
sentiment unique cision de l'acteur une
précision du phrasé parce qu'il y à un
texte parce qu'il ya une situation tout
ça va doit parfois convergé dans le même
sens parfois même se contredire aussi on
n'y arrive pas tout à fait de toute
façon et quand vous dites on ne peut pas
être vous avez déclaré sa un acteur
heureux et un administrateur parce que
une époque il était mondialement
question pour vous c'est quoi un acteur
heureux au nom en alternance ce moteur
qui joue way qui travaille aussi ce
qu'il a envie de dans le désir rencontre
le désert de metteur en scène et le
désir des autres mais corps et un
metteur en scène heureux or c'est un
metteur en scène qui arrive à créer dans
une équipe
un esprit de création et
qui à la fois arrive à préserver une
idée initiale à 20 puis carré va lui
donner forme initiale et en même temps
qu'ils soient surpris totalement surpris
totalement transformé ce temps les goûts
du ciel qu'il a eu d'accord et je me
souviens vous aviez 10e molière ses
truffes aux racines c'est godard vous en
souvenez pas échangés soit quelque peu
contraire et victor hugo je me demandais
qui c'était mais alors ça je n'en ai
laissé oui et ils font bien attention à
ce qu'on dit pour faire bien ça ah oui
ça faisait très bien c'est chouette
alors c'est non mais voit racing c'était
le format liste évidemment et molière
c'était le celui qui qui qui intégrait
la bouffonnerie qu'intégrer le mal le
truffaut c'est pas non plus un c'est
aussi un écran littéraire alors n'est
qu'à molière sera plus chabrol à ce
moment là il y en a tant changé à leur
meilleur non mais on peut trouver des
filiations siens voilà et dans votre
dernier roman fleuve pénélope gabriel le
personnage principal
les versaillais qui est versaillais
gabriel c'est votre second prénom ça ne
m'a pas aidé non plus vous parlez des
gens vous côtoyez parce que vous êtes en
train de tourner un film absolument un
peu rocambolesques en grèce et vous êtes
en train aussi de fuir un chagrin
d'amour
enfin vous gabriel et il ya un truc qui
m'avait amusé c'est que vous dites
tennis l'un tranquille jetez plus vite
d'autres sacs à buyo voilà chaque
dossier et je me demandais si une figure
de style connu ça ou c'est sûr de sud
très connue c'est dans homère ses
pensées l'antiquité achille laurent
odadjian d'achille
eh ben voilà ce sont des expressions
générique qui fait quand soudain
personnage
voilà sans qu'on ait à écrire de ligne
et pourquoi présence huit corps devient
archétypique et alors on pourrait denis
dire denis le alors justement gabriel
c'est celui que j'ai qui échappe à puce
et oui mais là oublions gabriel et denis
podalydès le jeu pour savais pas le
surdoué le dévoreur sûrement pas non
plus souhaité non non on n'a pas de vent
trouvera pas ce que vous faites quand
même j'aurais d'hondschoote polyglotte
voulu ah oui vous avez un très jeune qui
est un petit peu
j'ai appris un peu le gré mais voilà
décor c'est avec poli peut-être comme
les pôles et oui j'adore podalydès alors
d'accord et donc là vous allez montez
donc cette pièce qui sera jouée des
femmes est jusqu'à fin juillet jusqu'au
11 janvier à la comédie française en
alternance voilà un beau courage travail
bien notre merci et celui a très vite
ouais j'espère